Zombieland the zombie tacular land of
zombies guns and awesome okay so I've
been looking forward to zombie land ever
since I saw the trailer last summer
probably because I'm a dude and thus
I've had the dream that all guys have
you guys out there know what dream I'm
talking about you know the dream where
all of mankind has become flesh-eating
zombies or other forms of the Walking
Dead and you must gather arms fortify
shoot drive and do what you must to
survive the post-apocalyptic world of
zombies blood and mayhem yeah that's the
guy dream sorry to break it to you
ladies but yes your dude has had and has
loved that dream and no it's not weird
every guy has that dream I have a dream
see it's like a rite of passage but as
the release a zombie lion got closer I
started reading reviews and statements
saying that zombie land appeals to all
genres and 99.9% of movies that try to
appeal to all genres usually end up
spreading themselves thin and never
really appealing to one genre in short
the movie sucks usually but I [ __ ]
loved zombie land like from the
beginning credits to the end loved it it
was everything I wanted it to be the
movies main character is Columbus played
by Jesse Eisenberg a 20-something year
old socially neurotic awkward guy who
kind of reminds me of Michael Cera and
Andy samberg's love child who's strict
rules of survival horror have kept him
alive in Zombieland
he then teams up with mr. balls out net
appreciate it
zombie basher extraordinaire Tallahassee
played by the mr. Woody Harrelson and
then throw an Emma Stone for some zombie
killing hotness and you have a definite
recipe for the zombie tacular land of
zombies guns and awesome this movie
definitely hits all the marks for just
an enjoyable movie I mean the plot isn't
much deeper than we have to get from
point A to point B and survive doing it
but you have your zombie killing
satisfaction and you laugh your ass off
at all the funny parts and yes there is
a nice substantial amount of ludicrous
and funny but there are even a couple of
surprisingly touching moments thrown in
there I mean who knew and even in the
inevitable downtime of resting up and
bonding you know that part in the movie
that happens about halfway in where they
have a little RNR and you're like dude
either kill zombies or make me laugh
well they fortify and rest up and you
laugh your ass off at the rolling joke
in this segment that I am NOT going to
ruin for you because I [ __ ] hate
spoilers and I will not ruin this one
for you but if you were a fan of movies
you will [ __ ] die laughing
guaranteed yes we guys only need a
handful of things to survive and sustain
life and a good zombie movie ranks up
there at about six on the list
one two three four five and six [ __ ]
that just give thumbs up to zombies
instead of tits [ __ ] I did dammit
but yes number six on the list is indeed
a movie about the zombie tacular land of
zombies guns and awesome action zombies
and funny as hell this movie's
definitely a movie meant to let you just
sit back and enjoy the little things so
go see it and then go home and play dead
rising to capture that zombie killing
badass cowboy feeling for yourself
because you know you're going to end yes
every girl or woman in the auditorium
loved this movie too so I'm not leaving
you out ladies you too will enjoy zombie
land I'm just saying this movie's strong
enough for a chick but ph-balanced for
us dudes